[موسيقى]
وقال ل
حسنا
[موسيقى]
بجانب النخيل
من الماء
وما بعدها
أنا أعرف من أجلك
[موسيقى]
ص
الفم الصغير
يتحمل
يقول دعنا نقول
لتحقيق الفائدة
ص
[موسيقى]
أوه
[يضحك]
الارض
[موسيقى]
في الطريق
رقم
شارع
و
نصلح أكثر
يؤكد badiola
الآن
انا ذاهب لدعوة
د
[موسيقى]
و اكثر
مرحبا
[موسيقى]
اثنين
أوه
تايلور
فى الحال
هناك حيث هو
إلى الين
جودة
ص
مستقيم
[تصفيق]
يمكن
مجلس المدينة يدفع لي لا
دين
أم لا
البرد
كيف
لدي حياة
مجرد غسل قادم
من العمل
[موسيقى]
ناسا
[يضحك]
أخيرا
ساعتين
[موسيقى]
كانوا
أنا
أو
م
بعض
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ص
بدلاً من الاضطرار إلى قول ذلك
في ذلك الوقت
هيه
[موسيقى]
من تعرف
ماذا او ما
ص
الوادي
[يضحك]
[موسيقى]
بعض
في تحقيق السمع
نحن نتوق إلى الكراهية
[موسيقى]
أوه
سعيدة
القفزة من Tandilense ما المرشد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]